[Applause]
is it gonna be like this all the time
all right let's start with 101.
102 follow that with three one one
we're four one one who wants to know
anything
hi Brennan hi Brandon right here say hi
I'm Daniel Moto Academy digital
um huge congratulations this is such an
amazing moment for you
um I just really want to know how do you
feel right in this moment and what does
winning this award mean to you I feel a
bit light in the head
um this is actually kind of heavy
one arm might be longer than the other
by the end of the evening
I guess it means that um
I'm gonna have to find a job
um I'm grateful for this because of the
number of people who
worked
during the time of covid that we all
lived under
and we
we had to be very careful with one
another to stay safe and I think of all
the films we've seen this year there's a
secret ingredient and my guess is that
it's it's that concern that we we showed
for one another and for the work that we
do because
we all lived under an existential threat
we didn't know if there would be a
tomorrow so
going to make a film with this gravity
just reinforced how important it is
to perform as if it's the first and last
time you ever will
that's all I got
all right let's move on to number 311
and we will follow that with number 324.
Brendan back here to your right
to your right this way 311 not four not
four one one but uh Margaret Carrero
with KNX news first of all
congratulations what a phenomenal
performance I'm curious what Drew you to
the role and how fulfilling this win is
for you uh Darren Aronofsky was going to
make a film
um any actress like a moth to the flame
for that
um and he told me that it was story
about a man who
has been overeating and it's harming him
and he's very lonely
and
he wants to reconcile with this with his
child if he can and that's about all I
knew
and of course he showed me the script
I
wasn't intensely moved by it much in the
same way I learned that Darren was when
he first saw the stage play in New York
10 years earlier that
Sam D Hunter had written
Darren was very quite forthright that
this would be a challenging part in
just terms of
what it would take to create Charlie and
his body and
luckily he had now Oscar winner Adrian
Moreau to do my makeup
but it was my job
to
play Charlie from the inside out and
there's to create him from the outside
in
um
in company of Hong chow and Sadie sink
who's incredible I mean I watched that
kid win the game ball every day I had a
front row seat believe me she's scary
good
um Samantha Morton I'm actually kind of
sad that our marriage didn't work out
um
I think it's a film that's going to
change some hearts and Minds
and that feels good
feels really good
okay we will do 324 followed by our
final question in the virtual Press Room
hi Brendan over right here braffy irmac
Out magazine
um
uh congratulations first of all thank
you so um queer storytelling has come a
long way since you started in Gods and
Monsters which is also an Oscar winning
film right
um so how rewarding was it to bring a
voice to a complicated queer character
like Charlie and how does it feel
getting recognized for it from the
academy you've also had a lot of gay
fans you forgot to cure a throughout the
year so the gays love you so
[Applause]
I love you right back
um
Charlie's so much more than just a gay
man he's a father he's an educator
he's
he's a truth seeker and
that he fell
hopelessly inconveniently in love with
whomever is immaterial
he's someone who found love lost it and
then found it again
I think that
that's something that we can all take a
page from and know that
with perseverance
if you put one foot in front of the
other what Charlie did
go to the light
believe me
if I can do it you can too
good things will happen
and
we'll move on to our final question from
the virtual Press Room her campus you're
up
hi Brendan this is Cameron Cruz from her
campus I just want to say
congratulations to start off
um
so this past year has just been a huge
comeback for you and you know the
internet has been rooting for you
everyone has been on your side so what
has this past year meant to you and what
was the first thought in your head when
you heard your name called
um this has been incredibly rewarding
and affirming and it's
given me
um
a lesson in humility and gratitude what
did I hear
when I first heard my name um
I I heard my name but I thought that
can't be right
but it was
so I guess I should get up there and say
something quick
um
I'm sorry now I know what the metaverse
really looks like here
and thank you to all my
my internet friends who've been so
generous and
I hope that I live up to this
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you